Turquía ha confirmado esta mañana el
cierre según Turquía temporal según
Rusia indefinido del centro de
coordinación conjunta que se creó en
julio de este mismo año en Estambul a
través del acuerdo que al que llegaron a
Ucrania y Rusia con la mediación de
Naciones Unidas y de Turquía para
permitir las exportaciones de grano y
cereal que había sido bloqueado en
Ucrania después de la invasión rusa en
febrero de este año Turquía ha explicado
Hoy después del comunicado de ayer
asegurando Rusia que rompía el acuerdo
que el acuerdo será roto sí aunque será
temporalmente y que se espera que te
entre hoy y mañana los barcos que
salieron cargados de cereal de Ucrania
hace unos pocos días que ahora mismo
están esperando en Estambul para ser
inspeccionados serán inspeccionados y se
permitirá que continúen con sus rutas en
los próximos días sin embargo ha
confirmado Turquía que no saldrán más
barcos desde los puertos de Odessa y del
sur de Ucrania hasta que se confirme
hasta que se pueda renegociar otra vez
el acuerdo dice Turquía que quiere
renegociar y quiere reunido las dos
partes otra vez encima de la mesa algo
difícil sobre todo por la parte rusa que
se retiró unilateralmente de este
acuerdo y por la parte ucraniana que he
dicho hoy el ministro de exteriores
dimitroculeva que está retirada Rusia
demuestra que no se puede hablar
negociar con los rusos ni con Moscú